welcome everybody to this webinar
on quantum save cryptography today i'll
discuss
how to secure today's data
against the computers of tomorrow my
name is christian paquin
i am a principal program manager with
microsoft research security and
cryptography team
so before we begin i'll talk a little
bit more about me
my favorite subject so
we've heard a lot lately about the
quantum computer
it's everywhere in the news uh
it's a big research subject
and i've been hearing about quantum
computers for a long time
about 25 years ago i was a young student
at the university of montreal
where under the supervision of gel braza
who
was a quantum computing pioneer
co-inventor of the quantum key
distribution
and quantum teleportation and we were
trying to develop
quantum cryptography and all sorts of
double ideas
after my studies i had to take a more
practical turn
to earn a paycheck so i went into uh
applied cryptography and and into the
industry
uh where i worked for many years as a
crypto engineers
and a bit more than 10 years ago i ended
up
at microsoft and i'm currently in the
microsoft
research security and crypto team and
we're working on cutting-edge
cryptography
all sorts of new research ideas that
will end up in
products and services in five to ten
years
our current focus is post quantum
cryptography or quantum safe
cryptography
which is a subject of this webinar and
excuse me and so now
that you know about me let's talk about
this subject
um quantum revolution is as i said a
really big subject
conventional computers are built with uh
normal with the normal laws of newtonian
newton laws of physics
a bit is zero one and you can manipulate
it and we can do all sorts of things
with that
but if you build a computer using
particles that follows the laws of
quantum mechanics you get
all new sets of properties that allow us
to build
incredible algorithms and solve problems
we didn't know we could solve before
so a a quantum bit a qubit
instead of being only zero or one can be
zero and one at the same time
in a kind of superposition and also
quantum particles if you make them
interact and separate them they can
become entangled
and by manipulating one you can change
the state of the other one
so using these properties
quantum computer experts have developed
new algorithms and new ideas and
and bring forward the quantum revolution
and now that since we've known
uh a couple last decades uh what we
could do with quantum algorithmics
uh there's been a this race this effort
to
actually build such a computer and uh
my colleagues at microsoft are very
involved in that uh we're we're
have colleagues trying to build the chip
um to realize a computer
all the way up to quantum software to
operate these new machines
you can download today a quantum
development kit
to plug into visual studio for example
recently my colleague anita presented a
webinar on the subject so
i'll refer you to uh to that
the url that you see on the screen here
to to learn more about quantum computer
what's interesting for us now is
the impact of quantum computing
on cryptography although quantum
computing will bring
a revolution in the
information theory landscape it will
actually
be very catastrophic for the the world
of of information security
indeed a quantum computer
it's it's as if it was developed
designed to break cryptography
one of the first quantum algorithms that
was discovered
by peter shore and excuse my um
geekiness here by representing
uh the great peter shores this dart
shore here
he discovered in 1994 an algorithm
to factor large integers and
find the discrete logarithm of the of
large integers
which are the underlying mathematical
problems
uh giving the security to the rsa and
the dsa
and defiant the cryptographic systems
and also the elliptic curve variants of
these
problems so using a quantum computer one
could break
these very important security algorithms
and that would signify that
most or in in this case basically all
the cryptography we use on the internet
today
uh would be broken that is your https
your tls connections and your browser
your private messaging systems your ssh
protocol to uh to connect to
to web servers your bitcoins your
certificates
your software update channels all of
these would be compromised
by a quantum computer and
estimates say that the quantum computer
could be built
within 10 to 15 years
so there are some people that think that
a quantum computer will never be built
some others think it might take you know
just five years
as security practitioners we have to be
prudent and we have to
take the worst case into consideration
and a
a decade-ish uh estimate
it gives it gives us a good idea by when
we need to
to migrate to something that is quantum
safe
so we need to develop a new type of
cryptography
that um that is
that resists a quantum computer not to
say that is a special
magical algorithm that that no quantum
computer could break
but just one that we don't know how to
break
with quantum algorithms
so you might wonder why would we need to
act now if we have 10 to 15 years
why can't we wait uh you know nine years
and deal with it
just like we dealt with y2k and it was
very last minute
if you're old enough to remember um
we'll deal with that later just in the
nick of time to replace
uh just before we plug in the new
quantum computer
well the reason is that the data that
circulates on the internet today is a
risk
because let's say i'm exchanging data
communicating securely one an adversary
could take this
this encrypted data store it for
however long it needs to decrypt it
later with the help of a quantum
computer
and we know adversaries around the world
today are powerful enough that they're
able to
record large parts of the internet
traffic
secondly updating standards in which
this cryptography is used will take a
long time
tls ssh these are all developed by
large committees and everybody needs to
agree and we need to define new ways to
use
new algorithms and new mechanisms in
these protocols
um and another point is that
to update the cryptography we use in our
software
we need to test and realize the impact
these will have
new cryptographic algorithms might have
bigger keys bigger messages
signatures they might might run slower
than rsa
and also just physically modifying
the the the algorithms in the code might
be difficult
we had this experience in the past from
migrating from let's say ash functions
md5 to sha-1 to shot to 56
and sometimes it's just hard because
there are assumptions made by crypto
developers
hard coding all the algorithms in there
and we want to make it
easy to move away from these now taking
all this into consideration
let's say you have data that need to be
secure for a certain
amount of time let's say 10 years um
you're accommodating you have health
data with your with your
hospital systems your trade secrets you
you you have the secret recipe of coke
that you're communicating
uh with your your web servers then if
this data needs to be secured for more
then let's say 10 years plus the time
needed to change the protocols plus the
time needed
to update the software that's when you
run the clock backward
and and it gives you the start date at
which you need to start migrating away
from the current cryptography
and for many threat model that means
time to start is
today or even better yesterday
so what are we doing about this well
turns out that
academia has been has been ready has
been has been
expecting this and i apologize for the
small uh
fonts here on this slide and don't
expect you to read any of this
just to give you an illustration of
what's going on um
nist is the national institute of
standards and technologies
it is a um the the standard bodies
in the united states that dictates what
uh
the government agencies need to use as
far as cryptography
but it is the de facto standard
organization of the world because
its standards get replicated all over
the planet
and they made a call uh in in 2017
uh for replacement of our
classical algorithms that are
susceptible to the quantum computer
and they requested new new encryption
mechanisms key exchange mechanism and
new signature algorithms
so a large body of researchers
submitted um proposals they were 69 in a
round one
it took some time up to two years to to
analyze these
then they cut in a thanos fashion here
almost half of these a bit more than
half of these
and similar ones got merged together and
we arrived in a round two
uh with 26 left in the race
and we are now just
uh before the announcements of a third
round where
fewer options will be fewer algorithms
will remain after
a third round and these will
be further studied and some draft
standards will show up in
2022 so in two to four years um
so we're really close to having a a new
set of proposals for
for replacements
for as far as quantum safe cryptography
so my colleagues um at msr have been
very active in this
in this case um we
you'll see in this slide i present uh
four of uh proposals that we submitted
to nist
in collaboration with other
organizations and other researchers
so it's a big collaboration from with
academia
and the industry the first one is called
a frodo chem
it is a key exchange mechanism based on
the learning with errors problem
the second one is called psych which is
super
singular isogeny elliptic curves this is
the closest algorithm
in in all the competition that
it's the closest algorithm to electric
curves which is the current state of the
art so it has a very nice properties
in fact my colleague craig costello as a
just recently presented a webinar on the
subject
and i recommend you you check it out if
you want to learn more
about this cryptographic system
we also have two signature algorithms uh
one's called picnic
it's based on zero knowledge proofs hash
functions and block ciphers
i mentioned i mentioned the shore
algorithm earlier that breaks all
the asymmetric cryptography that we have
there is another type of of ciphers in
cryptography called symmetric
uh ciphers that are um
for example block ciphers like aes and
hash functions
and these one are affected by the are
affected by the quantum computers
uh but they are not uh broken in a
catastrophic manner
which can just double the key size or
the hash size and then we
were able to resist the quantum computer
for these so picnic in this case is
based on these type of
of primitives and lastly we have a q
tesla
it's based on the ring variation of the
learning with errors
and it's a fairly efficient signature
algorithms
so all of these and the the goal of the
webinar is not to go over
all of these in details they all have
their own website with
way more detail
so the goal of the webinar or however is
to say okay how can we use
this new cryptography how can we
integrate it into our protocols
and applications and services and to to
protect the data that we have today
against the the quantum computer of
tomorrow
well that seems a fairly difficult task
given the number of
algorithms floating around how do you
start where do you stop
what do you do so to answer this
question we
we joined this effort called the open
quantum safe
project this is a collaborative open
source project
led by the university of waterloo and
in which we developed a framework c
library
that integrates all the new post quantum
algorithms
and in turn we take this framework and
we integrate it into
popular application
or popular uh open source libraries
that uh that develop or that implement
popular protocols
for example we integrate into openssl
into boring ssl
if you want to try the new post quantum
algorithms into tls
we also integrate into openssh and
openvpn
if you're not a c developer you might
want to try it
from a different language so we provide
wrappers
in c plus c sharp go java and python
and there are other ones in the work
so i invite you to go visit this website
openquantumsave.org
for all the information and the link to
our github account
so given this project now we
um we that allowed us
to to experiment with many of these
algorithms
including our owns but also uh from
different variants and flavors of of
algorithms
in all these protocols which are
essentially the basis of every
cryptographic cryptography used on the
internet
and i'm going to discuss next a
uh interesting results that we had
into uh tls and ssh
so the first question we asked ourselves
is what is the impact of taking these
new algorithms
and integrating them into these
protocols so
elliptic curve the fieldman and and rsa
we know very well
how they behave and they perform into
tls and ssh but these new algorithms
it's not so clear some of them have
really large keys some of them are
really slow some of them
big signatures some of them use
implementations that are non-common
so the first exercise was to try them
all essentially
but um the trust we have today
in in the classical algorithms like rsa
and dsa
comes from the fact that they've been
around for a very long time like rsa was
developed in 1976
and the reason that everybody trusted is
because nobody was able to break it um
it's a bit like code code packages
we we have trusts and packages have been
around a long time they've been audited
by many different people
but uh the shiny new piece of software
might not be the most secure because
nobody looked at it
so it's the same for these algorithms it
might take a while to gain confidence
so the first um
the first thing we want to do when when
we're going to deploy these new
algorithms is to deploy them in a hybrid
fashion
a hybrid manner in which we combine the
security of the classical schemes like
rsa
and dsa and the fieldman and combine it
with a post quantum scheme
in a way that if either one is secure
then
the hybrid combination will also be
secure
and this is very useful because it
provides us
the security of the scheme that we have
today and it gives us a safety net
in case we have to face quantum attack
in the future so how this is achieved is
that
in tls for example you if you you share
rsa key or ecdhl electric curve
defeat element key you don't actually
use the rsa key directly to encrypt the
data during the session
what you do is you negotiate between the
client and server at the beginning using
that algorithm
to derive a uh
a master secret that's and that's used
to derive
a an encryption key for aes which is a
very efficient symmetric algorithm
and then you can carry on the
conversation using aes
so given that we can do that
conversation
as we did before but also in parallel
have another one
that negotiates a post quantum
secret and then we can mix them in the
key derivation function built in
tls the kdf and then out comes
this hybrid key we can use so
it works well because tls and ssh they
already have this ability to
negotiate which algorithm you want to
use
uh however they they don't have the
ability to negotiate two algorithms at
the same and be able to use them at the
same time
so uh there are two ways we can go
around that
the first one is we can define a new
scheme
like this on the screen this new hello
my name is
ecdhe p256 site p 4
3 4 34. so what i mean
what what that means is that we can just
invent a new scheme
instead of being ecdhe the electric
curve diffie element the ephemeral
version
or psyc and we can just say it's a new
one that's ecdhe
and psych together so what's nice about
this approach is that you don't have to
change the protocols you don't have to
change the implementation
you just define a new algorithm and
under
under the cover and the crypto library
you can
do the ecdh operations and the elliptic
curve
operation sorry and the psyc operations
and then you can combine the results
concatenate them
and just present it to the the tls layer
that sends it on the wire
and then when you get a message you
split them up and you operate ecdhg and
psyc
and then that's completely transparent
to all the tls layer
so it's the easiest thing to implement
but also could result in a
big combination of schemes because for
all the classical skins you want to
support and all the
quantum ones makes many combinations in
between
another approach would be to to define a
new mechanism to negotiate independently
the classical
and the post quantum one and that
require
requires changes to the protocol and the
implementation
so our paper goes over the various
options and i encourage you to take a
look at it if you're interested in the
details
but the important things to consider is
when you do modify the protocol you need
to take into consideration backward
compatibility a lot of the tls
platinum implementations are not only in
the in software they're also in a
hardware
optimization machines and so you want to
make sure that
your modifications won't break these uh
these machines
also you have to consider the
performance the latency the data flow
you don't want to
add new messages for this negotiation
or introduce new data flows that weren't
there
so i'll spend a
few minutes here to discuss
the tlas the tls case study so tls
is arguably the most popular security
algorithm
it's it's used everywhere it's hd that's
what protects https
and um in our
paper and also that's what we've
implemented in the open quantum safe
project
uh we we have two integrations one in
tls 1.2
and one in tls 1.3 that's the one i'm
going to discuss now
that's basically the new version of the
protocol
in tls 1.3 you only
have access to the elliptic curve type
of exchange
they've done away with rsa to preserve a
perfect forward secrecy
so in order to use our post quantum
algorithms we kind of have to cheat and
we masquerade as elliptic curves
so that's just a kind of a
a current workaround until the
specification
recognizes and allow other algorithms
which will be the case when
uh nist publishes these new standards
but for now we kind of just pretend that
we are elliptic curves and
and then everything works very nicely we
integrate in the the key share message
that's highlighted in the little green
square there
the keyshare extension and we just
uh expose our new algorithmic types the
new curves
and then that allow us to uh to derive
the right
key for all the algorithms for frodo and
psyc and all the other ones
so tls has built-in limits on how big
things can be all the
public keys and signatures can be in the
messages
um for example it's 2 to the 16 minus 1
bytes for
public keys and signatures and
certificates can be
slightly larger 2 to 24. open ssl for
example the implementation of
of the standard uh as smaller limits
it's mostly to prevent denial of service
attacks because
you know rsa is the biggest one we had
so far even though the spec
might support bigger algorithms in
reality there is none so
the the implementers decided to limit
further down
the sizes of the the artifacts that are
exchanged
so in our integrations we hit a few a
few of these
limits and i'll talk about that later
but uh
for the most case most of the
post-quantum algorithms that we tried
work nicely in tls and we have
integrated that
in both open ssl and boring ssl the the
there's their test tools client and
servers and also in apache and nginx
you'll see the link here on a github
project for the openssl fork that
integrates the
the uh the open quantum safe algorithms
and uh well speaking of that project i
will just
show you a quick demo now of a
tls 1.3 connection that has a hybrid
key exchange that's ecdhe
using the nis p256 curve in a hybrid
mode with a frodo algorithm
and for authentication we we
created a ecdsa p256
certificate as a hybrid with q tesla
p1
switch now we should see the little
console here
so uh cryptographic demos are
quite often boring because not much is
happening on the screen it's not like a
nice
ui demo um
so you'll see the connection it'll just
say it's going to work but the the main
point of the demo is that if you use
openssl
the main takeaway is that nothing
changes however you use
to use the openssl tool uh you can just
continue using as is you specify the new
algorithms and all works
so the integration is pretty seamless so
that's the point of the demo
here on the screen you'll see that we
have we're
starting a we'll start a server that's
going to listen to
offer tls 1.3 connections the
certificate it's going to use is a
pcdsa22256 with q tesla
and that's it so it's going to launch
that now it's waiting for connections
and in my other window here i have the
client ready to go
so the client is going to request a
connection to that
web server and it's going to request a
specific
curve for the key exchange in this case
ecdhep256
in combination with frodo so when i
click
when i start the server the client here
the request going to be made and there's
going to be two negotiations in parallel
one ecdhe and one with
frodo resulting in in a successful
exchange
now i've run these these tools in debug
mode so we can see
some output so we
in fact can see that tls 1.3 was used
and if i scroll up a little to see the
algorithms that were used
we notice that the signature that's
protecting the exchanges indeed ecdsa
with q tesla in combination
and the key
that was used for the encryption was
p256 and
frodo hybrid so voila just like that
we're able to um
use open ssl with post quantum tools
so the heavy burden of integrating the
post content cryptography was done by
the oqs project
and you as a user you can just go use
open ssl as you did before
and you have post quantum protection
right away
so the second thing we looked at in
the paper and the project was ssh
ssh is kind of more the same so i won't
spend too much time on it but
there's another key exchange another
authentication mechanisms in which we
also provide
hybrid mode and there are also
size limits in this case two to the two
to the 32 bytes four for message sizes
which is bigger than in tls
um and we also have a github project a
fork of the ssh
project that gives you quantum safe
cryptography
so i will also just show the tool um
it uses the protocol ssh2 from openssh
7.9
and instead of using frodo and nq tesla
and
now i'm going to use psyc as a hybrid
post quantum algorithm in combination
with picnic
so it's interesting that psych is
slightly slower than its
its other uh key exchange mechanism
and picnic has slightly larger
signatures but for ssh
unlike tls where you have many
connections a second potentially
ssh is a very uh kind of a low bandwidth
protocol you can
you you you communicate once with a
server
and uh and that's it so it's a slower
algorithms are not penalized and might
in fact provide
better security in this case so
back to the console here i have a very
large
common line ready to launch a ssh daemon
here
that's the ssh server part and i've
pre-generated the keys
here to simplify the demo but i'm gonna
only accept psyc and ecdh and site
combination hybrid
key exchanges and the only algorithm
signature algorithms i accept will be
p256 ecdsa
with picnic l1fs
so the server is launched it's going to
ask me to authenticate
[Music]
we don't want hackers to run my
fake servers in my stead so there it is
it's
launched and the client is also a very
big
command line ready to go with similar
arguments
and again the point of the demo is not
to understand what's going on there but
understand that
if you use ssh you can use it as you did
before and it's
going to just work with the new quantum
algorithms
also running that in
debug mode to see the output and
scrolling back up we see
that they've used the picnic key
successfully
and oh here is the
key exchange key i would use was indeed
psych in combination with ecdhe
and the host signature key was indeed
the ecdsa p256 with picnic
there we are so another
interesting thing that we went through
in the paper is to try all
the algorithms that we had access to in
the open quantum safe project
and again the
the goal here is not just to to read all
of them
if you're interested in one particular
algorithm you can check the paper to see
uh how it performed and how it was
integrated if there were some
integration notes
for it but most of the key exchange
algorithms work pretty well across
the board in tls and ssh
a green check mark means everything was
fine a yellow check mark
meant that some messages were
where they're valid messages in the
specification in the tls and ssh
protocol
but they were too big for the
implementation they reach a limit
in in openssl in this case
so we just had to increase some buffers
in the implementation and it worked
some others we couldn't make work for
example nts which is a
code based system and also the same
thing for classic mclees
simply too large of public keys and they
were hitting all sorts of
limits inside the code base that we
couldn't easily fix
for signatures we add a lot more
things we had to tweak because the post
quantum proposed ones of
you know larger signatures and keys
but most of them were able to fit after
some modifications to the
to the the base programs which is to be
expected when you integrate new
algorithms
and just very few couldn't work
so the one x red mark here in tls was
picnic the first the round one version
uh the picnic team in the second round
of the nist competition made updates
and provided new parameters that indeed
did
fit into tls nicely like picnic 2 here
and the rainbow
algorithm had two big public keys and
then they were
providing some error failures here in
ssh
so um that was for just
the integration of the algorithms
themselves could we fit them
another question that we ask ourselves
is what would be the performance impact
of these algorithms uh would we hit uh
some algorithms are slower than others
so what would be the effect
of of these algorithms in these
protocols
so we made an er we had another paper
that discussed this
we created two experiments for tls
specifically
and one we simulated some connections
uh inside one big linux machine
in which we control the latency and the
packet loss
rate and the other one we
we tested the retrieval of various size
web pages
across different vms around the globe
so let me discuss this quickly another
very dense slide
i apologize just for pretty graphics you
don't have to read the details it's just
to show kind of a
a trend and and the details are in the
paper
if you're interested but what i'd like
to just
highlight for the first experiment is
that
without you know a full internet wide
system
to to test multiple clients with
multiple servers
we decided to build this framework which
allowed us to replicate these these
conditions
uh in the lab so with a
linux vm with fairly large
with 64 cores we used
a characteristic of the linux kernel
which is called the
network emulator in which you can
control
uh the network conditions you can add
some latency you can add some
packet loss rate and
these type of things so we created a
virtual ethernet
devices for client and server and using
the openssl s time
tool to measure connection time to an
nginx server we're able to measures
to measure um the the tls establishment
time for various round trip
the rtts ranging from 6 to 196
for them and changing the packet loss
probability from 0 to 20
at various clicks so what we observed is
that
for most case for for fairly um
for really non-noisy channels so uh
packet loss rate smaller than three
percent everything was fine you know
faster algorithms perform well but as we
as we increase the error rate to three
to five percent
then larger algorithms get penalized a
little bit more because
uh their messages need to be fragmented
across multiple packets
and the chances that one of them will
get lost
and would require retransmission uh
increases
so um you see that in these graphs the
the blue lines that that
takes longer are the ones with with uh
bigger keys in this case
so i there's a lot of technical data in
this paper
uh i encourage you to take a look at it
if you
you want to see the details the the
second experiment we had
was to experiment with actual web page
retrieval
because after looking at some surveys
which
said that a typical web page is around
two megabytes
um so the cost of doing the crypto
is can be very small if you compare it
with the total
load time of a web page especially if
this webpage is further away
so to test that we add a virtual machine
a client that communicated with other
four virtual machines across the globe
from the one that was next to
to it and one all around the planet in
australia
and we also measures uh
to testing retrieving pages are one
kilobyte 10 kilobyte 100 kilobytes and
a thousand which is one megabytes and
what we observed
is that um kind of as expected the
the further away the connection is in
the bigger the web page the
less significant the tls establishment
cost is and why is that interesting is
that
i've been talking about using quantum
cryptography
using it today in a hybrid mode to
protect the data that's that's
um sent across wires every day
today and the question a deployer might
have is that okay what's going to be the
cost
not just of the development cost but
how how slow the connection is going to
be if i add a second algorithm on top of
it
well the answer is that for most
practical cases if you're sending
a normal internet data
the answer might be not too bad so all
of these
tests were done with hybrid key
exchanges combining
the the state-of-the-art elliptic curve
ecdhe uh that's used today
by itself and compared with the same
algorithm
in conjunction in a hybrid mode with
with some other quantum algorithms
so uh that's kind of good news
for experimenters that want to try these
algorithms
and see that the price to pay to get
this extra protection is
in reality not too bad so these are
basically things we can try today so
another
fun uh project that we had
was uh has to do with vpns this vpn is
an important
uh protocol and openvpn is a popular
project that uses
tls for protection so we integrated our
open ssl
fork into openvpn
and we're able to create this quantum
secure vpn
project so what's that useful for is
that
there are a lot of applications uh
legacy applications
that we will not be able to modify
because nobody's
deploy is working on them or developing
them they're just there and
so one way to protect their data is to
wrap
their classical rsa protection let's say
with
a oops a quantum tunnel
with a quantum to tunnel the
communication through a
quantum state vpn and then voila
no quantum adversary will be able to
break the encryption
of the legacy application in order to
test that
we uh decided to make a little
experiment
some of our colleagues are working on
project natick
which is a data center module that's
literally quite underwater in the ocean
on the coast of scotland and the goal is
to bring the data closer to the
customers and also you know to use the
the cooling
aspects of the ocean and we
ran an experiment using this open vpn
project
that's been running for a long time now
from our redmond headquarters
all the way to uh to scotland
and and the reason we we picked that use
case is that
that's a real life scenario of data
center security
data center to data center security and
it's a test bed without real customer
data so we're
able to to experiment safely and also if
we can't make it work
uh in this type of conditions then we're
confident we could make it work
anywhere on the planet because that
little seal there
that you see in the picture well that's
um that's the type of visitors we get to
that data center
unlike the cannot send the technician
very easily down there
so you can read about this project and
the
natick experiment at these urls and um
that's uh yeah that's the openvpn
integration
so in conclusion
that that i think it's a fact
to to say that quantum computers are
coming as
security practitioners we have to be
ready we have to
uh make sure that the threat model we
have today
will will still be valid and will resist
the quantum computers
of tomorrow so we have to make sure our
cryptography
is quantum safe i provided a lot of
information today on
how how we can do that how we can
move forward not only at the academic
cryptographic level
what which type of algorithms should we
use but also
how to integrate uh these new ideas
these new ciphers into our protocols
applications and services give you a lot
of links you can go and try and
experiment with
and we're happy to hear back from you if
you have
comments feedback suggestions
you have my contact information here the
url below is the our team page with the
links to all the
the projects you've seen in in this
webinar
so that concludes uh my presentation
uh i'll be happy to uh answer your
questions
in the live q a that follows thank you
well hello everybody um christian paquin
i hope you enjoyed this uh webinar
and we'll now be moving on to a live q a
portion of the presentation so
i already got a bunch of questions
that i've answered in the little q a
widget
in the webinar page i'll be
answering a few more for the next 15
minutes or so
um first i'd like to
surface a couple of questions i've seen
appear a couple times
i'd like to clarify uh some of the
difference
uh between classical and quantum attacks
and also the difference between a the
post quantum cryptography
and and and what is known as quantum
cryptography or quantum key distribution
so first um everything i presented today
the post-quantum cryptography or quantum
safe cryptography
are cryptographic algorithms
that are just normal algorithms
implemented with
conventional computers the same way you
would implement rsa or ecdh
it's just that we call them post quantum
or quantum safe
because we don't know we're not aware of
any way to break
these new algorithms the same way
that we know how to break rsa and ecdh
with a quantum computer
using the shore algorithm
so the the new label um the only
difference with these new algorithms is
that we're not aware of any attacks it
doesn't mean they don't exist
in fact they could we could be we could
break them with a conventional computers
they might have classical attacks that
we don't know about
but we we until until we find an attack
we we label them quantum safe
and that doesn't mean because it was
released uh you know
a year or two ago that that were
satisfied we'll need many years of
cryptanalysis both classical and quantum
cryptanalysis to gain confidence in
these new algorithms
so that was the first question the
second question i a few questions
we're asking the difference between um
what is attack like symmetric versus uh
asymmetric
crypto primitives so symmetric
primitives are like aes
and sha to 56 the hash functions the
block ciphers
these ones are not susceptible to the
shore algorithm
there's another algorithm called the
grover algorithm that can be used to
speed up exhausted search on the key
space and in order to deal with that you
simply have to double
uh roughly double the the key size or
the
hash size and then you're safe so we
don't we're not too too troubled by
these algorithms
on the flip side everything that's as
symmetric no not symmetric
um so asymmetric crypto primitives such
as rsa and everything that's based on
discrete log like this element
elliptic curves um so these ones are
completely broken there's a polynomial
algorithm against them so
these are the ones that we need to
replace
i also got a couple of questions
regarding quantum key distribution
and why why do we need post quantum
cryptography
if we have quantum key distribution well
first
just to to say what q the qkd is quantum
key distribution is a mechanism to
exchange a classical key using
quantum mechanics and typically
establishing a dedicated line between
two parties
and then they can exchange the key
securely
and detect the presence of adversaries
the thing is that that existed for a
long time and
you don't need a quantum computer to run
it or or to break it
you can deploy that today you can buy it
it's just it's not compatible with the
the
data model the trust models that we use
on the internet we can have dedicated
lines between every
every client and servers that exist on
the internet so we use this pki model
that provides us trust that we can
connect to
parties that we don't know by by
verifying signatures
that are that have been certified by a
trusted party
so these signatures you cannot do with
qkd and and
and the ones that we use today um
ecdsa for example are they are not
quantum safe and they need to be
replaced
so qkd can still be in the run for uh
you know uh taking over the the industry
they
they have not succeeded so far and uh
the fact that we're migrating to post
quantum cryptography doesn't change
anything about that
so these were some of the questions
that were asked let me
see um yeah there were some questions
regarding
the nist round three so you've i've told
you at the beginning of the presentation
that um nist
was doing this multi-phase
standardization effort to
to find quantum safe algorithms and
nobody knows exactly when the next phase
will start
and there's kind of a presumption that
that that might happen
really soon maybe well this summer
and and we're not sure if we're going to
go into a phase 3
or or if they're going to decide
on new algorithms right away
presumably they'll have a phase three
and there are already
been uh updates uh most of the quantum
schemes that are
still in the competition have made
updates in april
um to uh in
expecting a phase three and in oqs in
the open quantum safe project we
we've collected these and we will start
integrating them as soon as we're done
with
our current release which we've just
tagged this week and as a release can
the date number two
so as soon as that's done and we can put
in the new material
and uh it will percolate down to all our
depending forks like openssl and openssh
um there was
another question also they were asking
um
somebody was really worried about their
bitcoins
and i must uh apologize for putting that
at the beginning of the slide it's kind
of a
a little bit of a t not teasing but
uh i'd like to make a distinction
between
um encryption algorithms and signature
algorithms
so um encryption algorithms are
kind of endangered today because
everything that's encrypted
with a cryptography that can be broken
by a quantum computer
doesn't need to be decrypted today it
can be decrypted in 20 years when
somebody builds an effective quantum
computer
so your trust model your data
lifetime model my income pass you know
these
these decade period so if you want the
data to be secure in 20 years
you need to protect it accordingly today
but for signature
is a bit different you can't back
authenticate
uh or backsign something in systems
with something 20 years ago so in order
to fool
a pki system would to authenticate to
break a signature algorithm you need
a inactive attack with a quantum
computer so these will be more prevalent
uh as we approach uh the day that a
quantum computer can be built
and since in bitcoin in these type of
systems
uh a lot of the signatures are done with
ecdsa
so these will need to be migrated over
time but not as urgently as we need to
update
the the encryption keys in
tls and ssh because the data that's
exchanged today
is a risk using these
um let's see
oh i also had another question regarding
how if we in the open quantum safe
project if we will
implement or support other
protocols then ssh and tls there were
some questions about
s mime um so the
as you've seen the open quantum safe
project is a highly collaborative
effort so a lot of the development is
is done on a volunteer basis so anybody
who's interested to
uh contribute data is invited to do so
and i encourage everyone to go look
at these resource links uh either
our microsoft team they just you know uh
do a web search
micro msr post quantum crypto and you'll
find our page or just go on the resource
link to the right
and the openquantumsafeproject.org
and um and there you'll find all the
projects we're working on
and if there is an application you'd
like to
test with post quantum cryptography well
either you can
do the work and submit it back to our
project or you can
ask us on our on our platforms on a
github
to see if we can get somebody interested
in doing it
so our general mandate is to try to
anticipate
what would be the changes what would be
the impact of migrating to post quantum
cryptography and we're doing the
incubation work now
in order to avoid surprises later when
when it's going to be time to
to to make the switch
and we're almost out of time so i will
answer one last question
um this question i got uh the beginning
of the webinar related to uh
hybrid um hybrid modes i
discussed the hybrid uh techniques
in the in the webinar in which uh we
we're going to um we can combine a
classical algorithm with a post quantum
one
in order to get the best of both world
and we see that as
really important as the first phase of
transition because even if nis
publishes new standards in 10 to uh
sorry in a year or two then
the the industry as a whole might not be
totally
well satisfied with the new algorithms
or
will not trust it as it does the
currently deployed one
so deploying in a hybrid mode we see is
going to be
of great importance to gain confidence
and during the transition and
while also protecting our our data
so we'd like to see more work in the
area and we're certainly doing a lot of
all of our prototypes use hybrid modes
and where we'd like to get more feedback
from the community
on how of the best way to to approach
this problem
so i think
i went over pretty much all the
questions
so with this i would like to thank you
very much
for attending this msr webinar
on quantum save cryptography as i said i
encourage you to visit
the links that are posted to the right
of the webpage and
if you have any questions feel free to
to reach out and engage
either myself or the open quantum safe
project
in order to take this work forward
and thank you very much